[Music]
no my fuzzy cottontail do you think
she'll have my head for being late no i
i really must be it's time to
you think one of these cakes is magical
not that one oh allow me to shield it
from your eyes your majesty
you were born in the jungle you were
raised by wolves
so cool by the way
where's mowgli come with me i'll keep
you safe
wouldn't you love to have a dog like
this look at her to your left no not
that far rotate your oh
if you ever come to the jungle you'll be
my guest thanks but no thanks i'm an
inside cat man
have any special skills or talents
bull riding
[Music]
i'll see you at high noon
uh can it be 3 30
after school
please
[Music]
once again the marshall needs a sidekick
to save him from danger i'm not his
sidekick that's right
i work alone i'm his partner
i did not need your help
of course not
what are these sparkles they're memories
left behind by other people it's so
strange i've never met anyone who could
see the sparkles that's the part you
find strange give me a break you can
talk to ghosts
i wouldn't believe anything that she
tells you these will be yummy they do
look good
wait i thought frankenstein was a
monster you've seen him too
the only way to make my creator
remorseful is to destroy all of humanity
okay
that's a little much
where were you traveling from today when
your cab broke down driving around town
going wherever the fair takes me
that's helpful
what are your friends like are they
talking bears
you sure have a colorful imagination
donna
you're alive
if you don't mind i'm at a very exciting
part
i figured it out i'm a fictional
character from a book written by an
obscure writer and i've been brought
here by your ghost friend i'm a little
bit disappointed that i am fictitious
you'll always be real nice thank
you my crew disappeared i don't need a
new one
this rats alone can't run a ship
who wants to walk the plank
thanks buddy
i'm sorry for not being loyal to you
santiago
pirates forever
[Music]
why did try to release these characters
from the book maybe we need to ask
ghost rider can you hear us the ghost
camp the whole city ken